it's time for drew's news summertime
edition
[Music]
where we sift through the news and the
internet in search of good gold and with
me at the desk
is my favorite news prospector ross
matthey yeah hey
i'm drew's little gold nugget is what i
am you are a little
nugget and you are all gold we've got
viral stories that stormed the internet
and we're starting with a man in the uk
who spent six
years to achieve his personal goal of
parking in
every spot in his supermarket parking
lot
i love this story i do because people
are odd and they do odd things but odd
is beautiful
distractify says that gareth wilde loves
parking lots and he started with his
project
with an overhead shot of the sainsbury
parking lot from google earth
and he used that photo to make a
color-coded map of the spots and then he
methodically tracked his progress
in a color spreadsheet and now he shared
a cheat sheet of the best and worst
spots in the lot
hats off gareth i'm not sure where you
concocted up this idea
but i like it ross we all have our
unique passions and interests
you know stains i don't know what are
yours
uh i i think i'm perfectly normal i
think this is bonkers
to be honest i mean god good for you you
know if this if this
satisfied something that you needed i'm
glad you got it
but i don't get it i don't have that
thing like you you love a stain and you
have to get it out and you think about
it right
and you know what's funny is i thought
oh maybe like it's sort of like
a like a compulsive thing you know but
my stains isn't compulsive it's pure
passion okay well okay the only thing i
could think of that's a little okay a
little weird that i do
and it's just something that i enjoy
watching
the 90-day fiance it's not 90-day fiance
i have no shame when it comes to 90-day
fiance i don't think that's weird at all
i never thought i'd be talking about
that show on a weekly basis but i do
because of you i mean i do i feel bad
about that yeah a little bit
but you really should be watching it and
you know when you watch it no but the
thing that i watch
it's not like a task that i do i'm not
methodical about getting it done but
it's weird that i enjoy it i love
watching chiropractic videos
on youtube they are all they're cracked
up to be
they are so when i thought like what is
something weird that you do that's the
one thing
is that weird i love it you do
yeah i was nervous to say it out loud to
you oh no
i would never judge that i find it
fascinating what what's the fascination
it's about the satisfying of the
and then better you know the crack and
then better so maybe that's what this
guy's
he's it he feels like it's satisfying to
hit every spot and
maybe that i'm trying to understand you
[Laughter]
i don't know that we'll find common
ground on parking spots but maybe
human to human we understand each other
all right next if we're talking
viral stories we've got to talk about
tick tock yahoo life reports
this simple cleaning hack drew get ready
it's a cleaning hack
and it's racked up over 13 million views
it's a way to clean
up without a dust pan because we've all
swept
right and then you try to get in the
dustpan it just goes everywhere here's
how you do it
first you sweep the floor like you
usually do into a little dust tape
then wet the edge of a paper towel and
lay it lay it down
then sweep the dirt pile right on top of
the
onto the wet paper towel and it sticks
drew
i love this because i will tell you
god bless you dustpans but you suck
yeah thank you for your service but we
can do better dustpans don't do
it and you're trying to get the funny
dust bunny on the thing and then you
lift it up and you put all this effort
into it
i'm like what is going on here i know
and god forbid there's a breeze as
you're walking to the garbage can
boom it's over not to mention you're
then like sticky pulling off the hairs
and
you know a dustpan i like a broom
i look at a broom and i get hot i look
at a dustpan
and it's cold frigid yeah so when it
comes to this tick tock it's a clean
sweep
i am in and thank you so much rossi for
bringing this
information to my life you're welcome i
know you love that one picture who's
going to be wedding pa
wedding uh towels tonight miss barry
moore
was it paper towels or regular towels
it's a paper towel oh
i know even better you know why i'm
fully god look at her
because when you finish you can fold it
up
and then do one last polish with it one
satisfying
thank you rossie welcome drew oh you
always make life better
thank you to everyone watching and we
can't wait to see you again soon
[Music]
you